[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
fight fight fight fight fight fight
fight fight
and it's gonna be much of a fight I
don't know I don't know we'll see I'll
give you some predictions what I think
about Chris Christie getting in the race
and how it actually is bad for
Ron DeSantis not exactly Donald Trump
that's the that's the thing it's
horrible for Ron DeSantis for Chris
Chris at the end of the race absolutely
horrible and the reason why is Chris
Christie is going to announce in New
Hampshire like a presidential candidate
actually would not on Twitter with Elon
where it [__] crashes and burns
that's how you would do it and the other
thing is Chris Christie's going to focus
on New Hampshire and Iowa
just like Ron DeSantis is focused on
Iowa and picking up those Iowa votes the
the disgruntled
fractured Trump Maga vote that maybe in
Iowa or New Hampshire here's the thing
is Chris Christie knows more about
politics and presidential politic
politics obviously more than DeSantis
does and the reason why is because Chris
Christie is announcing in New Hampshire
you know why that's significant do you
know why it is that Chris Christie is
smart enough to announce in New
Hampshire because Chris Christie knows
he needs to be number two
he can't be number one he's not gonna be
number one in the polls immediately but
he needs to be number two
so how do you do that is you gain
support in a very Trump State Republican
primary in New Hampshire is Trump Trump
trump
Chris Christie knows this so Chris
Christie is going right after Trump
Rhonda santis is trying to pick up
low-hanging fruit here because he's a
[__] coward and he's a [__] and he
won't go after Donald Trump it's really
pathetic if you want the honest truth
and really if you if you're gonna beat
Trump you're really gonna have to batter
him hard you're not gonna you're not
gonna wanna just try to [__] duck his
punches Ron
and have your surrogates on Twitter do
it for you
like literally that's that's Ron
desantis's strategy is to try to win
Iowa right
not have to land a punch on Trump
because he's terrified that the Maga
cult will turn against him
so he can't land a punch so he sends out
his surrogates on Twitter and on social
media to bash Trump to get people to to
to the side of DeSantis by bashing Trump
I'm all for all this by the way every
single [__] bit of it this is what I
want this is what you should want
you should want them to [__] eat each
other
tear each other apart
burn each other down and piss on each
other's ashes that's exactly what we
want
I mean think of think about think about
the debt ceiling deal the only people
that are [__] mad about it is Maga
that those I mean and a few Democrats
who destroy everything anyways that's
right they destroy everything with their
[__] nonsense and their stupidity
because they're selfish pieces of [__]
that's right you're selfish
you're selfish if you if you say all or
nothing you're not a serious politician
and if you don't know who I'm talking
about well then go ahead and just do a
little bit of research and you'll know
that there's a few Democrats out there
and there's a few media heads out there
that absolutely are [__] selfish All
or Nothing All or Nothing get the [__]
out of here this isn't how government
and our democracy has ever worked ever
ever in the history of ever ever it
hasn't worked that way and it won't so
why are you acting like you can just
change it with the flip of a button
because you think you want to pull the
country to the left which it is to the
left
and we're moving more and more to the
left every [__] minute of every
[__] day and the reason why is
because of [__] boxes like Donald Trump
Ronda santis and now Chris Christie
you don't think this country's gonna go
oh my God look at these [__]
chuckleheads
look at him fighting over who did covet
worse I mean think about think about
this Rhonda santis and Donald Trump
can't figure out who did covet worse
they both sucked at it by the way
horrible [__] did a horrible
job both of them
no a pluses from me on covet from either
one of those [__] idiots
but think about Chris Christie and
Covenant entering this race Donald Trump
gave Chris Christie Cova damn near
killed the dude
damn near kill that [__]
and he's gonna go to New Hampshire
a New Hampshire is where you enter the
race Ron I don't know if you did any
studying on uh Republican primaries and
presidential primaries in general you
would have known not to do it on Twitter
you would have known to go to New
Hampshire
and announce your presidential losing
presidential bid just like Chris
Christie's gonna do
folks here's the skinny when Chris
Christie gets in this race and they
start fighting each other because
DeSantis is definitely going to attack
Chris Christie he's going to feel much
more comfortable and in his and and in
his [__] skin suit
fighting Chris Christie as opposed to
Donald Trump
he's gonna he's he's I I would bet that
the words that the words Jersey Shore
and Obama come up and Chris when Ron
DeSantis talks about Chris Christie the
very first time make no mistake
make no mistake Ron DeSantis is gonna go
straight for the Jersey Shore
the hurricane and Obama
watch hide and watch
but Chris Christie and Ronda santis are
going to fight this out for second place
and and the Battleground is going to be
Iowa and New Hampshire that's where
you're gonna keep seeing video photos
Ronda santis acting awkward and Chris
Christie looking looking like a
heavyweight in Iowa and New Hampshire
over and over and over and over and over
and over again
because they know
if neither one of them can win either
one of those States they're done
they're done they're finished
they have to be able to win at primary
and really honestly the Iowa straw poll
is important too
do you remember Scott Walker I know I
keep bringing him up but do you remember
Scott Walker he was the governor
he was governor Wisconsin
he was he he survived a recall vote
Scott Walker did they thought oh my God
he survived a recall this guy's gonna be
a national hero he's going to be next
president of the United States he looks
like a president
and his strategy was to win Iowa
that was his strategy I gotta win Iowa
[__] did he make it to Iowa
folks
you all the lessons that we've learned
about Trump and trumpism is all right
there in recent history it's all right
there
it's all right there because frankly
Donald Trump doesn't need Iowa or New
Hampshire to win he's going to win New
Hampshire
he likely will win Iowa
my guess is he sweeps Iowa he takes New
Hampshire and he's the only one in the
race left after that besides maybe some
outliers
that you've never even heard of
that's it
that's the rub
because Rhonda santis and Chris Christie
have already made it clear
that that's where the Battleground is
and that's where they're going to stake
their claim
which means which means all Trump has to
do is is convince his cult that it's all
witch hunts all the indictments are
witch hunts
all the election interference Ron
DeSantis is weak
and Chris Christie is a meanie head
it's literally what's gonna happen
it's gonna be awesome too to watch them
destroy each other I don't know if you
remember the 2016 primary
Chris Christie was in the 2016 primary
you remember that he was I mean he was
like oh this is it this is the favorite
Chris Christie
he's a badass he's such a hard
[__] you remember he says
exactly what he's what he feels
loser [__] loser
Ted Cruz
listen to me Ted Cruz made it further
than Chris Christie
oh [__] me oh man
Ted Cruz made it further in the
Republican primary than Chris Christie
and yeah and you think and you think
people are worried about Chris Christie
getting in the race get the [__] out of
here with that nonsense
that's ridiculous that's not gonna
happen
[Laughter]
oh boy oh it's Wednesday it's hump day
it's hump day it's hump day are you guys
excited
it's I'm excited it's getting warmer
outside summer's coming
and this is gonna be a great summer this
is going to be one of the best Summers
that we've had in politics in a long
time folks I mean a long time do you
have any idea how much content we're
gonna be a great
between pro-democracy content by the way
between now and then Jesus Christ
they're all they're oh man they they're
Chick-fil-A they're closing stores all
around the country according to them Bud
Light is in tatters you can't even find
a Bud Light anywhere
and Target Target they might as well
close every single one of those stores
too what a bunch of chuckleheads
can you can you see how great this is
gonna be
they're focused on boycotting companies
because they don't like certain
genitalias
on certain folks and they want to know
who's got what genetic this is literally
their their entire premise of their
boycott is people's genitalia I'm not
kidding you
is [__] it's fuckered it's it's weird
but this is where they're at remember
back
um in 2022
so last year during the summer
we had big huge fights
over actual substantive policy in this
country rather whether Republicans were
going to be allowed to take away Women's
Health Care or not
think about that
they they
struck down Roe v Wade and after they
they struck down Roe v Wade they got
really excited and really wanted to take
all Health Care away from all women like
everywhere take away their [__]
rights take away their [__] rights to
vote they were like yeah let's do this
[__] [__] them
if we're gonna take it away let's get
with it that didn't go well for him
right you remember that summer ah that
was a hell of a summer
now rewind back just a little further to
the year before
that's right 2021. remember that summer
it was the summer of CRT you remember
that I mean there was [__] school
board meeting after school board meeting
after school board meeting and they were
terrified terrified of CRT and mask I
mean just completely [__] afraid
remember that
remember that boy they'd come a long way
haven't they terrified a mask in CRT all
the way up to stripping women of their
rights to health care and banning
Women's Health Care trying to ban
Women's Health Care all around the
country and now here we are in this
summer they're obsessed obsessed with
who's got a dick and who doesn't
and who and who's printing rainbows in
support
I mean tomorrow's tomorrow marks June
1st the start of pride month here in
this country
they're in for a long [__] month of a
long [__] month of them buying
nothing them doing nothing them
supporting nothing I mean everything's
gonna be on the boycott table it's gonna
be [__] hilarious and none of it's
gonna work because they can't boycott
everything and by the way I told you
this the other day political boycotts
don't [__] work they don't work when
the left does them they don't [__]
work when the right does them they don't
[__] work Chick-fil-A is a great
example
think about it think about it think
about [__] Chick-fil-A
it was 10 years ago almost a decade ago
when the left decided they were gonna
boycott Chick-fil-A because Chick-fil-A
gave money and support of anti-lgbtq
causes which great don't ghost don't go
buy a chicken sandwich from Chick-fil-A
fine buy a cheeseburger from Burger King
or whatever restaurant you want they did
that it didn't hurt Chick-fil-A because
there was a backlash in politics there's
always a whiplash with these political
boycotts one side's like ah we're gonna
get rid of Chick-fil-A on the other
side's like yeah we're gonna go buy some
chicken sandwiches [__]
same way Bud Light same way with Target
same way with Coles or whoever the [__]
it is that you decide you're gonna
boycott listen the only thing that
really does any good at all
at all
is a is a full-on 100 public shaming
when it's not political right I mean it
may have something to do with policy in
general
but generally speaking it has to be
consensus outrage and consensus shame
and that's what if that's what works but
this political [__] where ow I don't
agree with Target having rainbows on
children's clothes because my little
fragile sensitivity is broken when you
let me know that there's gay people in
the world and people support them
it hurts my feelings so we're gonna
boycott you oh yeah that's gonna work
okay I I noticed [__] right Wingers
this morning are like oh look oh look
Chick-fil-A or no no what was it Kohl's
or was it Target I don't remember maybe
it was Target they're down one percent
in the stock market like oh my God you
[__] fools listen if stock prices are
any measure of anything then we'd all be
[__] Rich you dumb bastards the stock
market is not a [__] measure of
anything but but the richest of the the
richest pocketbooks you stupid bastards
and ain't got nothing to do with us not
a goddamn thing they let us participate
in 401ks to trick us into thinking that
the market has to do with us that's
literally what why they decided to let
average people have 401ks do you know
that did you know that 401ks were
originally designed for Rich
[__] they weren't gonna let us
have those goddamn things until they
realized you know what we could probably
convince them that the market is is is
their Market too and we could get them
to send us all their [__] money that
we can play around with and gamble with
if we just convince them that yeah the
Market's for you too look here's a 401k
for you to stick some money in and they
even did this thing for like 20 years
where the [__] the [__] employer
would put in some money for you right oh
yeah you put in a dollar we're putting
50 cents you put in two dollars we'll
match you a dollar into your 401k
and then eventually that [__] [__]
went away too didn't it yeah it did it
did and they got you convinced they got
you convinced that you're part of the
market and you're part of the grand
scheme of making everyone Rich when you
got I don't know a couple hundred
thousand dollars sitting in your 401k
and when a [__] tanks you ain't got
[__] and you're left holding the [__]
bag
that's just to make you think that's
just to make you think you know about
the stock market and you're
participating in the stock market you
ain't actually there [__] you're
50 Grand your 100 Grand your cup on a
grand that ain't it
we're talking about we're talking about
hundreds of millions of dollars that
these stupid bastards are playing with
every day every transaction and you
think one percent worries Target
[__] out of here
come on man
it'll be up by the end of the week it'll
be down next week it'll be up the week
after that
you think Target's worried about this
[__] hell no Target's worried about
brick and mortar stores going away
that's what [__] Target's worried
about you think they're worried about a
bunch of Toothless rednecks [__]
making Tick Tock videos about how oh we
hate rainbows and Target loves rainbows
so we hate Target
and by the end of the week we'll find
someone else to hate and we'll forget
all about Target
[__] out of here this nonsense
it's all dumb ass [__] but this summer
is gonna be great because of it think
about this they literally have a chance
right now think about this they have a
chance to really rethink their entire
party
they got a chance they they have they
have four Governors four [__]
governors in this race when Chris
Christie gets in they have Asha
Hutchinson from Arkansas Nikki Haley the
former Governor South Carolina they got
Ron DeSantis the fascist the fascist
Florida Hitler and they got Chris
Christie the former Governor of New
Jersey two-term governor of New Jersey
four Governors four Governors who were
executives
yeah
they could totally reshape their entire
party instead
what they're gonna do is fight why the
biggest [__] buffoon that they have
in their party is the one that should
get another shot at losing
that's what they're going to do this
summer and what we're gonna do is
[__] encourage them to fight each
other
to fight each other and call Donald
Trump a [__] loser that is the one
thing we have to do folks because he's
gonna win he's gonna win I don't care
how many I don't care how many [__]
I don't give a [__]
I don't give a [__] how many indictments
there are he's gonna win and I actually
solidify his win
because these [__] boneheads have
already done themselves a disservice and
I'm talking about the other people on
the stage when they're saying [__] like
oh it's yeah it's the Witch Hunt it's
all a political investigation it's all
about politics and and this shouldn't
happen and they shouldn't weaponize the
doj
they already are playing into Trump's
hand they're already playing in tamaga
the manga cult's hand they're already
giving the race to Trump when they say
that [__] have you heard one of these
[__] one now Chris Christie I
believe will be maybe the one who does
it
but have you heard one of these
[__] attack him on his criminal
ways no
no they know they can't call him a
criminal
they'll lose every [__] vote
every [__] vote because they even the
dumbest of the dumb
who who are thinking about supporting
Ron DeSantis over Trump still think
still think the government's coming
after all Republicans everywhere and
their election was rigged
and Donald Trump won and he's and he's
being it's a political Witch Hunt
they're convinced look look at Dustin
look at him here see
it's clearly which on genius see he's
convinced he's they've convinced him
he's a sheep and they fed in the food
he's even in my chat hey man it is a
Witch Hunt
so how in the [__] are they gonna un
unwind all this
how are they gonna unwind the fact
that Rhonda santis
and Chris Christie ASA Hutchinson Assa
Hutchinson Nikki Haley
uh Vivek which by the way we found out
the Vex uh campaign seems to be funded
by Saudis and it seems to be funded by
Saudis who funded the the live
tournament for Donald Trump maybe in
exchange for documents and classifying
information I wonder I wonder who's
responsible for vivek's run whoever
Vivek is Vivek is a presidential
candidate he runs around all over the
country saying some crazy ass [__] he
doesn't know anything about contemporary
history in general he doesn't know
anything about political history in
general
and for some reason he's oh yeah he's
everywhere he's oh he's a he's a star no
[__] Sherlock
kind of funny it seems like it seems
like
someone's trying to hand pick the person
they want to run as number two which I'm
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say for sure
but my guess is that Vivek
last a hell of a lot longer than Ron
DeSantis or Chris Christie in this race
I bet you still see Vivek who hasn't won
any delegates
in in super Tuesday
on the primaries that's right I bet you
do
and he won't win one delegate and he'll
still be in the race wonder where he's
getting his money wonder who's
encouraging him to run hmm I've been
asking those questions hell I'd have the
back on to ask him those [__]
questions in person if you dare to come
on this show
but this is the brain damage that they
have in their party folks
the brain damage is they don't know how
Cults work Chris Christie Rhonda Santos
Haley Vick
if they truly are think they're going to
be the nominee they just don't
understand how Cults work and you can
see it all too clear already these
people are not going to back away even
Kaylee mcinerney yesterday was attacked
by Trump my guess is within two or three
weeks when it's clear that Chris
Christie is more of a favorite than Ron
DeSantis I would imagine that Kaylee
mcanady comes out and says oh yeah Trump
he was just joking no big deal no big
deal I apologize to him and everything's
cool 100 bucks 100 bucks
I know it sounds crazy but that's what's
gonna happen that's what's gonna happen
that's what always happens with these
[__] chuckleheads
they don't like him
they don't want him
but they ain't got a choice they made
the [__] bed
now they gotta lay in it
and they gotta keep laying in it no
matter what happens here because what is
going to happen is Rhonda Santos and
Chris Christie are gonna fight in Iowa
and fight in New Hampshire for number
two and Donald Trump is going to walk
away with those delegates
and Come Away with the first two primary
wins which is going to solidify
his first ballot
win at the Republican National
Convention
next summer that's what will happen
because they can't win if they don't got
delegates at the convention it doesn't
matter what what he's charged with what
he's indicted for in any manner if he's
sitting in a prison cell somewhere as
long as that [__] has the
delegates he'll win
he'll win and if you think that you see
a path where Rhonda santis and Chris
Christie are gonna pick up these
delegates without winning Iowa or New
Hampshire either one of them one of them
at least you don't know how primaries
work and you don't know how incumbency
works and I know you're like Tony he's
not the president Donald Trump's not the
president but he's the incumbent here
a lot of these [__] moglodytes these
cult members believe he is
the president they believe he won
so he is the president Jesus Christ
there are some of them like eyes running
for a third term
that's the case it's unconstitutional
but Let Them Fight let him fight fight
fight fight fight not only just let him
fight not only let him fight
encourage the fight
take their gloves off give them brass
knuckles let them really bang each other
up bust each other's Jaws let's do it
folks let's you know you know what's
better than
you know it's been hypothetically
speaking hypothetically speaking you
know it's better than punching a Nazi
watching Nazis punch each other
that's fantastic I'm so glad you're here
as you are every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch if
you come from Texas Paul's Channel make
sure make sure you subscribe right now
Texas Paul was on before us he threw to
us make sure you subscribe right now to
the Tony Michaels podcast here on
YouTube also you can follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod you can
download every single episode audio
version of the podcast at Apple Spotify
and Google in the afternoon after we get
done editing it if you want to watch on
Facebook that's a great place to watch a
lot of people watch on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels follow us at the Tony
Michaels you'll be able to watch for
free on Facebook every single week Dan I
want to thank all the people over on
Twitch
well you guys are really come through on
the twitch thing it's incredible we've
got over 1200 followers now
and the subscriber count is way up
people are re-subscribing every single I
mean just 25 minutes ago we had someone
resubscribe we had someone just
subscribe just 17 minutes ago with Prime
and you can use your Prime account to
give us the subscription on Twitch but
here's the thing it's free to follow
yeah that's right you just go over and
you open up a Twitch account at
twitch.tv twitch.tv Tony Michaels open
your account follow us for free doesn't
cost you anything then if you want to
subscribe here's the free way to
subscribe which gives us Amazon's money
listen up if you want to give us
here at the Tony Michaels podcast
Amazon's money you just take your Prime
account and you link it to your Twitch
account
you get one free subscription with your
Prime account for Amazon gaming and you
use that free subscription to subscribe
to the Tony Michaels podcast on Twitch
and it gives us a couple bucks the
directions are right down in in the
description below or you can go to the
Tony michaels.com that's the
tonymichaels.com it's about the fourth
link down it says link Amazon and twitch
and by doing that all if you follow the
directions there you will be giving us
each month
a couple bucks of Amazon's money and you
got to renew it every month you got to
go into twitch and re-subscribe so if
you have set it up and you linked them
but you haven't re-subscribed in a while
go into twitch go to twitch.tv slash the
Tony Michaels and re-subscribe for this
month there on Twitch boy I'm excited
it's a great day we're gonna have Gabe
Sanchez on we're gonna watch some video
today of course stay up with the news I
I can't wait to talk about Tara Reid
dude do you hear this Tara Reid's a
Russian ass [__] asset no [__] Sherlock
everyone stick around we'll talk about
that more when we come back right after
this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
in Russia
oh my God are you gonna get more clear
I mean you know why would you defect a
Russia really
if you weren't you know a Russian asset
and at this point I mean and we watched
as Edward Snowden did the same thing
because he knew he's going to be
indicted so does that mean that Tara
Reid is seeking Refuge from Putin
um uh to possibly Stave off some time I
I have no idea these are just questions
that come in my head why the [__] would
she leave now right she's like oh I'm
frightened for my life Frank for your
life for what
listen you [__] out there that
think Joe Biden is some kind of feeble
you know decrepit man who can't put his
own shoes on who can't think for himself
really think he's some kind of
Mastermind World criminal or something
all right am I right I mean you gotta
decide man you really gotta figure it
out
is he is he some sort of [__]
scheming ass [__] that's gonna
take over the world and use Tara Reid as
a tool to take over the world or some
[__] or is he just dementia ridden and
can't find his
[__] marbles huh which is it you
really you [__] need to decide
this [__] just like you're gonna have a
lot of decisions to make this summer on
who the hell is gonna be your [__]
nominee
and the rakes aren't gonna stop folks
They're Gonna Keep placing their own
rakes in front of them to step on
speaking of that speaking of rakes you
have to go to store not beat Tony
michaels.com and check out the new let
them eat rake because boy oh man
they're never gonna stop digging their
political Graves so go to store.the
tonymichaels.com check out let them meet
rake we've already sold a ton of
t-shirts uh I'm not sure exactly how
many but boy it's a lot uh at least a
couple dozen already uh of the let them
meet Richards I'm gonna try to get some
hoodies this afternoon and some stickers
this afternoon I promise I'm gonna try
and get time to put more of those that
way we'll have more tomorrow so if
you're waiting on stickers or hoodies or
some other merch just hang in there with
us but if you want a t-shirt go to
store.d Tony michaels.com and get your
letting me right because they're gonna
have tons of rakes
that they're going to be stamping on
this tear read thing oh my God you talk
about a rake and they keep stepping on
the raid too they're like oh that rake
oh yeah oh that rake oh yeah let's step
on that one again
and now and and now and now they're
they're one in the hole remember she
just accused Joe Biden of
sexual harassment and or whatever she
accused him of I don't even remember do
you remember this
she was discredited it wasn't even close
to [__] true it was totally debunked
she kept at it kept at it kept at it now
she's defected to Russia
okay
I wonder I wonder why that could be
the [__] out of here man come on
and you think that's a sign that she's
somehow credible because people been
calling her Russia Russian asset this
whole time she's like you call me a
Russian ass said I'll sue you and then
she defects to Russia okay
you you [__] really do know how
to pick them let me tell you something
you really do know how to pick these
some [__] Trump DeSantis
oh man Stephen Miller Steve Bannon
[__] Mike Lindell
Sydney Powell Rudy Giuliani you
[__] really do know how to pick
your Heroes oh my God I
oh miss loveseat says Tony we want Pride
[__] em shirts and hats hey that's not a
bad idea
that's not a bad idea that's not a bad
idea you know what
I'll talk to Gabe Sanchez see what we
can work up pretty quickly and see if we
can get see if we can get some some
pride shirts and hats that's not a bad
idea I didn't even think about it to be
quite honest with you yeah it's not
really how I think about things I guess
you know I'm not like oh well let's do
that
that's a great idea thank you for the
idea you know what let's let's play a
little round of um
of shoot this [__] you want to shoot
this [__] if you got a question go ahead
and put it in the um go ahead and put it
in the chat there we'll talk a little
bit you can ask me a few questions I do
this thing called ask me anything on
patreon everyone really likes it and you
just ask me any question you want we do
it for like 30 minutes I'll answer all
the questions you ask in 30 minutes it's
on patreon you know patreon.com
if you join you can actually see the
past ones the links are all there but
this is kind of like what it's like this
shoot the [__] on the show here where
you at because I can't answer every
question on the show
I I do it on asking me anything but on
the show it's too many but we'll try it
here we'll just shoot the [__] so if you
got a question go ahead and ask it there
in the chat while we wait on Gabe
Sanchez he's got a few minutes am I
going to am am I going to the Iowa State
Fair no
no I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna follow the
[__] clips and the videos in the in
the media that comes out of the Iowa
State Fair and anything that's that's uh
relevant
but I mean again you're you're you're
really looking at with the Iowa State
Fair I mean I I wouldn't imagine
I would imagine that that Trump doesn't
even go to the State Fair he didn't do
retail politics he really doesn't need
to do retail politics that's why
DeSantis and and and Chris Christie are
already behind
speaking of being behind
now he's not that late he said five
minutes he's on him five minutes yeah
yeah yeah yeah no we're talking about
that they're asking if I'm gonna go the
Iowa State Fair
um and I said probably not because Trump
ain't gonna go so you know yeah why
would you go there's no I mean like who
else is really in the running Vivek
isn't really a running
personally that's a good point that's a
good point because I was talking about
him earlier you know what I think I
think vivec is in this all the way he
doesn't have any delegates and the guy's
still running in the very end because
he's funded by I don't know Saudis
I definitely think that Vivek is going
to run until the very last minute right
he's going to be that person and and the
way that he Brands himself is
anti-establishment because that's uh not
never been done before but he's going to
be anti-establishment and he's going to
talk about how he's there for the you
know until the very last and every
single dollar is going to be raised by
you the Grassroots that words and it's
your voice that's putting me into this
position and
then he's gonna try and say oh this is
why I should be you know
he because he's going to try and use
this as a position not VP
but he's gonna like if if if
some crazy world that Donald Trump did
win
he's gonna try and say like oh you know
what I should be I should be a Cabinet
member oh so you think Rebecca's
shooting for a position I think he's
just how this [__] works man you got
people that are wrong they're hoping to
get another position they're trying to
level up each time I've listened to him
speak in these spaces and I've watched
some clips of him that dude is getting
paid to run I don't yeah he's all and
not only that but like I don't know
wherever he's driving but he's always in
the back seat of that SUV well he's
always like I'm on the road where where
are you on the road no one has seen you
on the road or like at least why I mean
he's driving around in circles around
Mar-A-Lago I mean honestly I wouldn't be
surprised if that's why he's like hey
guys
well let's see
because you know that if Vivek lives in
Florida can't be the VP and I actually
believe when Trump gets a nomination I
don't think he's actually going to
select a running he was born in
Cincinnati Ohio
uh but he let's see
and Yale and Yale oh oh he's an elite
yeah you know what's funny about that
that [__] knows nothing about
contemporary history if you listen to
him and speak about contemporary history
especially political history you're like
what the [__] this guy doesn't know [__]
he's a bonehead like you're Harvard
educated Yale educated and you don't
know these things dude again I've said
it before and a great example is Ted
Cruz you don't have like you don't have
to be smart to go to these schools okay
the hard part is getting in it it does
it's I and I can tell you from uh well
sometimes that's the easy part depending
on who you are right yes but I can also
tell you from people that I know who
have gone to Harvard and Yale in brown
and Princeton and Dartmouth that they're
like oh yeah it's
incredibly hard to get in but once
you're in yeah you have to be a [__]
idiot to drop out right yeah it's no
it's no it's no [__] different than
any other college once again right uh I
don't know where he lives yeah now my
guess is my guess is that someone's
saying it here in the uh um I think it's
Deborah or yeah Deborah here on YouTube
she says that Vivek creep is another
icky fake white boy just like cash Patel
disgusting here's the thing is that it
might it might be that the same money
that's paying the whistleblowers hmm
is paying the back I've asked this
question since the first time I heard
that guy talk when he talks about Trump
I'm like ah this guy really sounds like
Trump's paying him to say this stupid
[__] yeah
Columbus Ohio oh so he he so he's
driving around in Ohio in the su he was
raised in Cincinnati and he lives from
what I've seen in Columbus Ohio and he's
raising two sons and uh you know do they
go with him in the SUV all the time or I
don't know I don't know here's here's
what I'll say I bet vivec doesn't get a
single delegate out of any of these
races and he's still running by the time
we get to the convention right yeah I'm
gonna support Donald Trump
now here's my other guess is that
yes yes
um they're pointing out vivex ties to
live the live golf tournament it's not
it's it's not rocket science and Gabe
can detest to this the first time I
heard this [__] talk in this in
Mario's Twitter space I was texting you
why I was talking I was like this
motherfucker's being paid by Trump to
run I can tell yeah there's no other
reason why you would like if you're if
you're supposed to be running against or
potentially against Donald Trump right
like why are you [__] sucking his
dick like why are you here why are you
why are you uh propping him up to be
like ah Donald Trump did some great no
the whole idea is you want to position
yourself as separate from the candidate
that you're running against you want to
say Hey you shouldn't vote for that guy
and maybe during the time he did some
great stuff and did Harlan Hitler buy
him that's a possibility yeah Robbie
asked that question
Hitler here's the thing Robbie I don't
think it's Harlan Hitler here I actually
believe that this this is this is the D
this is part of the deal that was made
about whatever information changed hands
for the live money for the live
tournament this is all part of the deal
this is all part of the deal this is all
part of the scheme
that that they're using with Saudi money
I believe now let's go back to the
primary because Chris Christie's going
to get in that's the big news this
morning ah Chris Christie he's gonna
announce it right New Hampshire yeah
next week Tuesday on a Tuesday in New
Hampshire which if you want to know how
to announce to uh run for president
that's how you actually do it not how
Ron DeSantis did it you go to New
Hampshire you stand in front of a crowd
with a microphone and you announce it
you're gonna run now yeah how many times
do you think I mean how many times does
he run now is this like number three
Chris Christie no it's two he ran in
2016 this one that's what I was saying
in the in the a block is that Chris
Christie you know for all those excited
about him running I just want to tell
you in 2016 Ted Cruz made it further
than Chris Christie okay so I don't know
if you're really I don't think you're
serious if you think Chris Christie's
gonna win a primary here but also like
you know as I was you know you were
texting me and then I was also watching
some of this other stuff that was
happening which is like Donald Trump
attacks Kaylee mcinany right oh that was
beautiful then the Trump Crowd Goes
after uh uh [__] why am I blinking
our name right now uh got the got
covered from Rudy's fart
um Jenna Ellis because she's now she's
now on the DeSantis yeah so now she's
getting attacked right so all yeah she's
gak not Matt
so you've got all these people who once
once [__] propped this guy up Chris
Christie was the one training Trump
during the debate prep when Trump had
covet they all [__] spread coven he
damn near killed him I know so the idea
that you have all of these people it's
also funny to think that any of these
people at one point thought well I'm
with Trump now I'm totally safe from any
further involvement either legal
problems or also personal attacks that
are done via Trump and his party but uh
Jenna Ellis last night was like oh
people are talking about how I was
divorced three times
that's the thing that you're coming out
with is like why is she divorced three
times I don't know was she divorced
twice I have no idea I don't know but
she was like oh the Trump Camp here hold
on I'll say that's that's weird though
that that's where they go right
says you're at Krispy Kremes that's
probably where Chris Christie will will
actually announce as well Krispy Kremes
it's I mean why not why wouldn't he why
wouldn't he hey look listen I you know
he's a big dude Chris Christie is a big
dude and the guy likes to eat but did
you notice that the recent Rhonda santis
photos it seems like either they
photoshopped the Trump weight off of him
or he's lost the Trump weight because
remember he got he got chubby to look
like Trump yeah yeah and then I think I
think I think DeSantis is kind of
thinning out because he can't beat Trump
anymore right he's taken he's he's not
wearing the Trump drag anymore this is
what I'm trying to say he's not going
somewhere in the high heels though you
know well I mean he's got to he's like 5
I've seen people criticize his pants
because they like they don't
they're talking about DeSantis or Trump
because I saw both uh DeSantis at least
Trump his pants kind of meet where the
shoes are DeSantis like they're they're
they're elevated above you know right
but he's got high waters but he's got
these but they're boots though he's
trying to show the cowboy boots off yeah
but they're not really cowboy boots well
right they're high heels
um I mean you know it's always
projection with these [__] but
I mean Trump trump wears high heels too
he just wears the heels in his shoes he
wears lifts right so he's gotta he's got
a big ass heel but then he's got a big
ass lift that's the reason why you know
they make fun of him for walking down
the ramp
right I don't actually think it's
because he can't walk down the ramp he
can't walk down the ramp but then
[__] lifts into shoes without losing
his shoe that's why he's got a shuffle
or or the lifts put him too far forward
so he's gotta like exactly well and he
doesn't want to come out of the shoe
right because I'm sure like no one wants
him to come out of his shoe well you
know I don't want him to come anything
um but here's the the back of his shoe
is probably like this right now it lifts
like right here so there's not much room
for his shoes do you think it's a custom
mold or it's one of those like as seen
on TV molds you know oh I would I would
imagine it's like it's like it's like
it's like leafed and fake gold and [__]
right it's probably got Trump printing
like just like spray paint right all
kinds of [__] stupid but I feel like
I've seen that exact product on oh yeah
Marshall where they're like are you do
you want to seem taller now put these
four inch heels you know it's like right
no they have they have infomercials out
there with like oh you're short here
here's some lifts right it increases
your height by three inches then no one
can tell wink like all the people who
know you aren't like you grew three
[__] inches man Roderick says he
walks like an emperor penguin
true it's true but I think it's because
of the lifts is the reason why he's yeah
down there you can't run with lifts on I
mean have you ever tried to run like
flip-flops it's also when that's also I
don't have my glass in front of me but
like that's also when he one of the
moments in which he tried to to drink
the glass with two hands again uh I
think that was the that speech was at
West West Point right it was like yes
yes it was it was it was the graduation
right because Biden had done that before
and he like runs up the ramp he's like
yeah yeah because Biden can run run he
can he can like do you can also ride a
bike it's pretty important do you know I
was I was telling my family last night
because we were talking about that and
they were talking about uh like Joe
Biden's age Donald Trump's age and I'm
like listen I I know the age thing is
fun to talk about but here's the thing
Joe Biden can ride a bike okay yeah I
would love if there was video of trump
just trying to get on a [__] bike
that would be hilarious I would pay
money to uh you know what if it means I
had to pay Elon Musk the eight dollars
he so desperately needs right now I'd be
willing to do that like if there is some
subscriber only content that somebody
had I'd be like [__] it I'll pay the age
I'll pay it just to see it just to see
it here's the uh you posted this um the
Jenna Ellis yeah tweet here's the here's
the image of it uh she says team Trump
is pushing a lie that's I've been
divorced three x
it's false I I don't okay so what yeah
so why this lie all right great question
why this lie Jenna why are they you know
you used to be T you were you were
running around the country advocating
for state legislators to steal the
election there's people gonna go to
prison in Georgia for your dumb ass and
because you defended Trump so why this
lie oh yeah there's a part of me that's
like I don't think she's out of the
woods yet no hell no and well Rudy
giuliani's definitely in trouble in
Georgia which she was she was Rudy's she
was right there shark fan man she was
there with uh with Sydney Powell she was
there with Rudy Giuliani when he was
leaking Inked on his face you know he's
farting covet on her okay she goes on to
say they want to destroy my character
you have character come on I've listened
to you speak you line sack cause [__]
you ain't got a character and make me
seem untrustworthy oh no [__] Sherlock
if you're untrustworthy you black person
who lied about the spreading the big lie
right well [__] she was remember Rusty
Bowers the speaker the Speaker of the
House in Arizona Republican speaker
Thousand Years doing a testify in front
of Congress the January 6 elect
committees like yeah Jenny Ellis and
Rudy Giuliani were in the room and I was
like where's the evidence they're like
ah we ain't got it he's like well I need
to have it I'm like man we'll get it to
you later and he's like does it exist or
like that's a good question and not only
that it was like oh well it's all like
Theory right and it's not real you don't
actually have anything anything concrete
that you can use here right oh then she
tries to drag us into it right the
leftist she says it's the lowest form of
political attack you advocated for this
[__] who has been giving these
kind of attacks since day one you dumb
[__] she says that's all we have it's no
better than leftist don't drag us into
this yeah you you slim it you guys you
guys are doing uh fun yeah don't grad I
don't want to be involved in your little
divorce say and how many times you
divorce fight I don't give a [__] how
many times you're divorced I don't care
I what I care about is that you tried to
steal our vote you had to try to steal
our democracy in his name and now you're
confused
divorced can we talk about the fact that
they're they're supposedly attacking her
for getting divorced meanwhile the dude
that they're that they're representing
into it
multiple times like the idea is crazy
that they're like oh man we're gonna so
get her for being a [__] and getting
divorced and it's like but that's manga
brain man that's brain for you isn't the
cult leader that you guys follow and and
just so happily give your money in life
savings to didn't that guy get divorced
multiple times and not only that it
wasn't like oh he was married then I got
divorced and then he dated and then he
got married then he got divorced and
then he dated no no each marriage he was
having an affair
and then got divorced paid out and then
got married so and not only one of them
one of them is [__] taking him down
in Manhattan right now with Alvin Bragg
so you know the idea that they're like
oh man oh god dude yeah you're divorced
three times and she's like oh they're
complaining because I'm divorced why
wouldn't you if you're So Pro DeSantis
and you're upset attack Trump Donald
Trump team is attacking you why wouldn't
you go after Trump and be like hey I
wasn't divorced three times but you know
who was Donald Trump well let's listen
to the rest of it here she says I think
all these character attacks against
everyone who supports are even
accurately Praises DeSantis will
backfire spectacularly wrong
I'm already seeing it from The Real
World that isn't the Twitter Bros Echo
chamber listen the real world the real
world no one knows who the [__] Rhonda
santis is and doesn't care dummy they
don't care the only place they care
about Ron DeSantis right now is on
Twitter that's it that's it
that's it not only that but like she has
to realize that nobody knew who the [__]
she was she was some ticket court
attorney in Colorado Colorado who has
been censured for telling up to 10 lies
about the election okay had to admit to
him yeah had to admit oh I lied I lied
and she really doesn't like when you uh
when you confront her in these Twitter
spaces which I've done at least a couple
times now because oh oh the attacks the
attacks oh these are so personal it's
like no they're not personal you said
these lies you admitted to the lies you
were censured by the state of Colorado
you're lucky you still even have your
law license right the ability to
actually practice law [__] blows my
mind right now
but you're uh you're you're upset again
it's the [__] leopard uh uh the
leopards eating people's faces parties
like yeah well they gave him leprosy
like oh yeah they'll eat the other
people's faces off right and now they're
coming eating their faces and they're
giving them leprosy you don't you don't
think
that this was gonna happen like you
supported a guy who built his platform
on attacking others on a personal level
and there was [__] no there was no
bar everything was allowed any sort of
attack you could attack children you
could attack wives you get attacked
random things like oh Ted Cruz is the
it's the [__] Zodiac Killer Ted
Cruz's dad was involved with the
assassination of JFK his wife is ugly
it's not like these are things that
Donald Trump did and the rest of the
party was like yeah that's not so bad
right yeah that's okay
this was the guy that you all propped up
and said huh
he's our president he's our goddamn
President right there he is our God our
Almighty our golden Captain we sit down
and kneel and pray before
and now you're getting upset that this
guy and his party are [__] attacking
you because you decided to endorse the
other candidate right you're like the
cult good until the cult comes back on
you
um animal mother over there on uh on
Twitch says Tony you should start a
segment called [__] and cucks
Ah that's not a bad eye it's not a bad
idea
[Music]
people sometimes don't like when I say
that word and some people love when I
say that word and the reason why you
love it is because I don't lie when I
when I put someone on that word right I
don't there's no no lies fan no lies
found speaking of speaking of calling
people names
um grandpa poopy pants last night called
Haley mcanany milk toast now I'm gonna
read this I'm gonna tell you what milk
toast is I had to look all this [__] up
because I'm a dumb [__] and I didn't
know it either but let me read this and
I'll tell you and I'll tell you why even
the left is really stupid about this uh
it says Kaylee milk toast uh macanoni
just gave out the wrong poll numbers on
Fox news I am 34 points up on De
sanctimonious not 25 up okay
girlfriend
um while 25 is great it's not 34 yeah no
[__] Sherlock why do you feel the need
to tell us the difference between
numbers
like what's the Delta I forget his
audience he's talking to here that
that's a good point he says she knew the
numbers was corrected upwards by the
group that did the poll the rhinos and
the globalists can have her what I don't
okay Fox News should only use real stars
as opposed to those fake ones I guess
he's he's digging at her and as opposed
to Tucker Carlson okay so milk toast
milk toast is a breakfast right and
apparently people are going after him
because he misspelled milk toast he
didn't actually misspell it here it's
actually two words and it's a breakfast
but there's a cartoon and I believe the
cartoon was drawn from 1893 to 1950.
this is my research here and it's um
it's called milk toast
um and I forget the full name of the
cartoon but it's a really timid [__]
um unsure character yeah spineless
character yeah yeah it's called milk
toast and it's spelled a little
different than what you would think milk
toast would be spelled now the reason
why I didn't know the reference is
because I wasn't [__] born in 1940
okay they stopped making this cartoon in
1950 and really honestly this statement
when he calls her milk toast only shows
his age that he's using that as a dig
number one number two you're missing the
entire point
when you [__] go after him on the
milk toast thing that he spelled it
wrong that's really stupid okay here's
why it's stupid because he's attacking
Kaylee mcineny who was his [__] press
secretary who again just like Janelle's
lied and lied and lied for him the day
of the Insurrection when he was trying
to commit a coup she was out defending
him committing a coup in real time in
real time that's and he's attacking her
and in two weeks let me tell you
something in two weeks Kaylee mcenany is
gonna be like oh no we're fine it was
just a joke no big deal
everything's cool because I want to keep
my temporary position in Fox News and
keep being on the air
um and I don't want to upset Grandpa and
get him to to to post about me anymore
well we mean milk toast but but the
damage is already done folks yeah this
is this is the first this is why we have
to encourage this I mean because not
only okay so there's that tweet and and
then I sent you the video of how it
followed up because it was like I don't
know within an hour an hour and a half
of him tweeting that chip Roy was on
chip Roy goes on to Fox News with Kaylee
mcinanny and Byron Donalds and decides
to throw some similar terminology right
he thinks he's being cool here with
shade because chip Roy is a dumb [__]
but here it is but hey folks we should
encourage this this is the infighting
that we want to have listen you know
starting with with you Congressman chip
Roy what is the realistic alternative to
this because I understand we wouldn't
formally default we can pay the interest
on our debt but our debt could be
downgraded and that could be
catastrophic so what is the realistic
alternative to this deal
well thanks Kaylee uh first of all you
know the everything that we're seeing
out of the bill that was put forward
this this deal this hatch this weekend
is pretty milk toast if uh if that word
might mean something to you
why are they why are they so unfunny
yeah they suck at this but also here's
the thing
he's such a dumb [__] really all right
so Chip Roy trying to be funny right
he's like oh it's pretty milk toast the
point of a joke is you don't have to
point out that it's a [__] joke you
don't have to explain it and break it
down and be like oh if that means
anything to you I guarantee that if you
just have pretty milk toast somebody
would make the connection already that
he says milk toast talking to Kaylee
mcinerney and an hour before that Donald
Trump posted [__] Kaylee Milton's
mcaninny it doesn't take a rocket
scientist but according for Maga or
according to Maga the way that they have
to get a joke across is to overtly hit
it on like over the head and be like Oh
Kaylee mcinay you know all about milk
toast right
Christina brings up a good boy you're on
YouTube she says what kind of name is
Chip Roy sounds like a terrible
chocolate chocolate my cookie okay so
here's the other thing too about this
Kaylee mcenany Trump thing okay what do
you have to understand about this in in
the realm of politics and especially in
this primary that they're running is if
Kaylee mcinany is going to stay on for
any certain amount of time in this eight
o'clock spot trumps knows whatever she
says is very important
um rather people will will gravitate
towards DeSantis or gravitate towards
someone else now the more people that
get in this race and fight for number
two the better it is for Trump so Trump
should be excited about Chris Christie
getting in this race now here's the
thing he's going to make sure that he
publicly tells his supporters when
Kaylee's doing this stuff on Fox news
she's sliding me and it's election
interference so support me when she says
[__] on TV but when Kaylee mcenany is
going to say Pro Trump step oh she's
going to be the best thing since sliced
bread not milk toast okay she's gonna be
the greatest thing uh and he's gonna
he's gonna post about it and she's gonna
say see he praised me because I did this
and I did that and blah blah blah blah
blah so it's all really stupid but we
should encourage it oh yeah we should
encourage this infighting and the reason
why we got to support uh encourage this
inviting is not because of the
candidates themselves or these
personalities themselves it's to
fracture their base it's to get their
base confused of what and who they're
supposed to believe because they have no
real principle they're like genitalia
genitalia genitalia semen semen in my
lemonade semen in my lemonade like
they're all over the place right dude
over the map it's crazy I mean like but
that's what happens when you spend all
of your effort not representing your
constituents or your District or the
people that voted you in you spend all
of your time with fake outrage and
owning the libs and trying to end
everything woke and what happens you now
find yourself with a party that is uh
potentially going to vote you out as
speaker and that's what's happening to
Kev McCarthy however this deal and I I
would assume that the deal is going to
go through no problem before June 5th oh
because here's the thing they can't not
do it or else they will look like bigger
if they don't let this pass
they will look like bigger idiots the L
will be just as bad but it'll be a
little bit smaller because they walked
in saying oh we're gonna demand this and
do this and blah blah and really you
know Joe Biden a master negotiator came
in and was like look I'm not giving you
any of that [__] okay we'll make some
compromises here but for the most part
you guys can go eat a bag of dicks and
so like that's what happened and now the
Republican party is looking at their
representatives to be like well what
didn't you get why didn't you guys do
what you want to do and again it won't
be as bad but they'll still have an L
that'll be it's like that that Meme of
Joe Biden hand in the L to the
Republican party and be like here you go
you still lost it's not as bad
when you said that Joe Biden told Maga
to go eat a big bag of dicks do you
think they're like whoa whoa you mean
like trans woman dicks no I don't know
if they I don't know if they first said
I don't they said that they might first
ask well how big is the bag right is it
like what like there wasn't any there
wasn't any debate for like oh man what
kind of dig is it's like well how big
like how big are they and how big is the
bag our audience uh semen toast Mister
says on YouTube
speaking of semen toast
Rhonda Santos uh he's got genitalia
record what record he was an island oh
my God
uh this guy this guy's such a dummy
right now you can tell like yeah
what his angle is here
um to try to say hey Trump only gets one
term but I get two like dude the Trump
voters they they think Trump's going to
be president for Life man they don't
care about democracy they don't care
about the [__] rules in reality I
don't know if you know how Cults work
but they really don't give a [__] about
what's real and what's not they're not
Tethered to reality so they don't give a
[__] that you think you're gonna win two
terms and let me tell you something if
Rondo Santos's cell in this primary is
he's gonna have two terms
he's gonna have to sell it to the rest
of the country in the general as well
which is not going to bode well with the
way he rocks around saying woke every
third word but let's listen to his
argument again he's making more closing
arguments Gabe Sanchez before it even
gets started listen to this bureaucracy
is so entrenched that I think we can
bring George Washington back and I don't
think he could fix it does he think we
can resurrect George well they believe
that Jesus resurrected from the dead so
why not George Washington but also like
okay George George Washington could be
resurrected from dude times have changed
and I I very much doubt that George
Washington would be able to comprehend
the [__] show that the Republican party
has created right they'd probably he'd
be like oh [__] it man send me back to
the Grave like he used to be like whoa
whoa wait you're afraid of rainbows yeah
wait wait wait wait he's like you're
afraid you guys are like gay people yo
man I'm gay like do you see the wig do
you see the shoes I wear come on man
every day is drag
what the [__] Okay let's listen to again
his weird closing argument here where
he's making in the beginning of the
campaign he clearly does not matter
anyways run for prison let's listen in
one single four-year term we must
restore sanity to our nation we can't
have every major institution in our
country going on ideological Joyrides we
have to be guided by reality
okay this I haven't heard anything this
is the same guy when he says we can't uh
we have to be have some reality this is
the same guy that's wanting to do all
the crazy ass fascist [__] in Florida
right am I is this the same guy yeah
yeah okay I just remember the guy who's
you know Banning books and right telling
people they can't go into certain
bathrooms you know he's also the one who
tried to fight the mouse but lost trying
to get rid of the biggest corporation
the biggest job maker in the state yeah
it seems like a lot of reality they're
all attacking companies that are big
donors to their campaigns right I love
the Chick-fil-A thing we'll get we'll
get to the Chick-fil-A thing
um a little more because people are are
really digging into the Chick-fil-A
semen lemonades by facts and by our
enduring principles we in the State of
Florida held the line when Freedom hung
in the balance
what what what what
that I I still didn't get anything that
he was saying did he have a policy in
there was he gonna was there anything he
was gonna deliver
nothing and like if you look at the
Chiron versus what he said
it was a lot of buzzwords it was never a
policy that he passed it was never a
proposal for policies that he wants to
push it was never how he's going to be
different than trump it was never the
how he's going to be better than Trump
it's not how he's going to improve the
country even with a fascist policy
mentioned nothing it was all buzzwords
it was all a bunch of adjectives it was
about a bunch of oh we had these woke
ideologies and these leftists and this
and that like but again nothing was said
that was actually of any sort of man
like hey here's this dumb policy that I
tried to push nothing not even that not
even that
it's really weird it's almost as weird
as this Joey thing that we discovered
yesterday
if you did not watch yesterday's episode
oh my God you missed you missed such a
good segment on Joey manorino I didn't
know Joey was until yesterday but I am
so glad I know who Joey is now because
it is unbelievably funny and hilarious
this this almost
almost out does the [__] Nick Adams
account on Twitter it almost it's close
it's close almost if you go if you go to
Joey's Twitter page and just search
Search the word semen
on his Twitter page he talks about trans
semen more than anyone I think on the
planet
why is he
talking about that I you know I he seems
to have semen brain like he can't focus
on anything but see well let me show you
one of the Tweets in a comment thread
that I found yesterday yeah yeah and
I've I found it interesting that that
Joey would would type this
um
he says here
uh because this is this is the response
to this this tweet here so he says
bookmark this tweet and this will be the
definite boycott list of pride month
2023 which I am renaming boycott month
the 2023 starting with the basics the
basics here gives inches but like Cole's
North Face and Target now again they're
only upset at these companies because of
their preference of genitalia or what
porn they're watching I'm not really
sure what it is he goes on to say in
this in this tweet he says more will be
added on the thread below subject to how
deep and do transgender stuff they get I
don't know what he means by how deep
into transgender stuff they get he means
but you know whatever Joey you're not
projecting at all
he says I will be sure to keep this
updated yeah but like when when you like
I thought that wait hold on okay okay
does that mean
that he's okay with some transgender
stuff or like there's a line that says
like once you hit trans no no no that's
right well listen to this so William
here questions him says I thought it was
just for companies pushing it on
children question mark but now it's any
company that has anything Pride related
question mark interesting right wing
tactic so William challenges him a bit
on this and Joey proceeds to tell us
exactly how he feels and his projection
here he says my personal red line is the
transgender stuff I don't care about the
regular Pride stuff if they throw the
flag with the Trans included they're on
my list dude you jerk off to transporn
100 I'm sure yeah 100 I'm definitely
doing a lot of research
[Music]
research in the transgender stuff
research research
which hey I don't care here you watch
whatever porn you want Joey that's
totally rude totally yeah if that's your
thing that's totally fine absolutely man
but but but our issue here on the show
and it should be everyone's issue is him
using that as an attack against a
marginalized Community attacking people
for just being themselves and look
if you're into that as your Kink or
whatever it is you're is that what your
preference is totally fine Joey yeah
sure but there's no need to attack other
people because you hate yourself or
you're part of a party that hates
themselves or hates other people
whatever it might be or be scared of a
rainbow it really is dumb stuff that
you're scared of rainbows speaking of
scared of rainbows Charlie Kirks
scared of the same rainbows now he
here's what he says about this
Chick-fil-A thing
um this this semen lemonade thing right
because it all started in the semen
lemonade thing went by God they really
so we really [__] he's taking this
off for semen in his lemonade uh Charlie
Kirk's like whoa whoa semen eliminated
Chick-fil-A let me get in on this he
says bloop the blueprint okay
pressure and demonized right-wing
companies to make them either go
bankrupt or become one of your own okay
listen to how he says this pressure and
demonize right wing companies yeah make
them either go bankrupt or become one of
your own then his median instinct is to
say look at Chick-fil-A
I mean I'm not saying that Chick-fil-A
isn't owned by some right Wingers yeah
Chick-fil-A in and of itself a
right-wing company because Charlie Kirk
believes that it is look what he's
saying he believes that right now he
goes on to say a decade ago the left
hated Chick-fil-A they wanted to crush
them and I remember this boycott it was
really stupid because political boycotts
don't work
I.E Chick-fil-A they're still around
people are still eating chicken
sandwiches brined and pickle juice okay
did you know
is that what is that what makes them
that's their secret interesting they
brine the chicken in pickle juice that's
why they put pickles cause they got to
do something on the pickles yeah yeah
yeah yeah brined and pickle juice I
didn't know I mean you know Chick-fil-A
is not bad but there's a lot of people
like oh it's the greatest I'm like the
waffle fries are better than the chicken
I like waffle fries
you want to know the honest read the
waffle fries are better than the chicken
sandwich but I I digress
Charlie goes on to wine here he says now
Chick-fil-A is bragging about Dei
statements and groveling to the New York
Times support what the [__] does that
mean he says you can't if they can't
break you
they make you join them this is how they
operate dude this is your plan this is
what you do this is all this is there
it's complete
utter project he probably got this out
of a right-wing email that they were
circulating he's like you know what this
is great content I'll just post this on
Twitter neck like it's the left doing
this I just ah man I I'm they put it on
the internet as if people can't just
simply search for this stuff and know
exactly what their talking points or
their point of views were at one point
right and the idea is like oh you know
they tried to cancel Chick-fil-A
okay fine that's you know anyone can do
that if they want uh
but are they upset that Chick-fil-A
stopped donating in like was in 2020 or
2021 or whatever stop donating to these
right-wing anti-lgbtq campaigns
is that what that's was that what
they're upset about
they're upset like yeah the company
stopped like doesn't mean the CEO hasn't
stopped right
but the company
Texas Paul made sure to correct us dill
pickles okay okay what Hey listen
there is no other kind of I read that
totally differently in my head what what
did you I don't know what you read it as
I read it as dickle juice
[Laughter]
I was like oh yeah Chick-fil-A yeah I
have a semen lemonade pickle juice
that's where my mind is right now man
why do you think do you think
Chick-fil-A is Gonna Change now that
they support lgbtq causes and have Dei
do you think do you think that they are
now going to brine their chicken and
dick juice
I mean look
uh maybe dickle juice I mean I look I
heard I I see dill pickle juice we're
talking about Chick-fil-A I hear digital
juice in my head immediately and that's
why I laughed I was like oh no that's
actually not what it says it says
something different have you finished
your your Joey what was that maybe you
can include the dickle juice I might
have to throw it down I haven't no no
I'm wrapping up the um
I'm wrapping up the Lauren bobert
Memorial Day One uh yeah yeah but I'm
gonna be doing because this is this
whole Chick-fil-A thing is part of a
larger uh story which is the Bud Light
the target it's all [__] fake and
it's weird
and it's not gonna work
especially because I just saw a clip
from Asin
um
yeah yeah and I haven't watched it yet
but it's yeah let's watch it Haley
mcenany
oh my God no [__] and it's [__] on
Trump until they start selling until
until they start selling tuck swimsuits
I am not going to be boycotting
Chick-fil-A oh
okay okay no so she likes that all right
by the way thank you Texas ball for
throwing from us today if you guys
aren't aware Texas Paul is on every
Tuesday but he's got a new show on
Wednesday mornings before us and he's
going to be throwing to us on Wednesday
so thank you Texas bro I caught a little
bit of it but I Was preparing for the
show so I didn't get to catch all of it
but thanks for throwing to us uh let's
see this is this is Kaylee
um liking the dickle juice then right it
sounds like I haven't seen the clip but
based on the caption that Aston wrote it
sounds like just from here oh my God
it's like 20 minutes ago
here's here's milk toast talking about
how she loves uh dickle juice let's
listen
mind many are questioning if the
backlash is starting to go too far oh
finally uh Chick-fil-A is founded by es
true Kathy he's a devout Southern
Baptist his son uh same a strong
Christian they close every Sunday you
know I'm in the airport I want
Chick-fil-A they're closed on Sunday
what she means is they're huge bigots
that's what she means yeah yeah her huge
bigots Southern Baptists
right they're bigots well what do you
think you have some mayo right but what
they do understand about business is
money is you can't necessarily be a
bigot in your business they discovered
that when people discovered they were
giving their [__] money to lgbtq and
anti-lgbtq
um organization
and they're like you know what we should
do some of this Dei thing and they did
the Dei thing and the rights like get
rid of them we don't want your giggle
juice and your semen lemonade anyways
um but
um Kaylee mcenany apparently likes the
bigotry she loves the bigotry and she he
probably wants some nickel juice let's
listen honor of the Sabbath until they
start selling tuck swimsuits um I'm not
going to be boycotting Chick-fil-A
they're a great company
uh dickle juice Count Me In ducked
swimming suits hi I'm out I love it yes
I just want to know at what point does
Ron DeSantis come in and say Chick-fil-A
is the devil because we got Kaylee
mcinanny saying that she's not gonna
she's not gonna boycott She's Not Gonna
Cancel Chick-fil-A right because she
understands it's [__] dumb right well
she also understands this the the actual
the ramifications of them to keep going
after companies like this because
corporations are going to go wait
Republicans aren't our friends now
they're not our [__] friends so we're
not gonna give them money nor are we
gonna Pander to those [__]
right as corporations but the other
thing too is like the fact that it was
kind of preview there in the Chiron is
that everyone's like ah Chick-fil-A
all this [__] right well here's the
thing the woman or the the guy uh
uh Eric Reynolds
was it because atlanta-based company
named Eric Reynolds the post of Vice
President of Dei in 2021
wait they're not gonna like it but he is
a black man oh no
oh no but the thing is
check this
2007 whoa whoa and he was promoted wow
VP of Dei in November 2021. what you're
telling me what you're telling me is
this is I know I know the way this this
what was that is going to go now this
isn't new what you're saying this isn't
new and this has been a deep state plant
since 2007 is that what you're saying
this has been a deep State woke
transplant no maybe pun intended there
transplant into Chick-fil-A in 2007 it
seems like a big conspiracy theory to me
I'm sure there's some meganomics
right now I've got the [__] equations
going around on it I know exactly how I
want to structure this what was that ah
this is beautiful thank you Kaylee
mcenany you're awesome
sandwich and the semen lemonades
speaking of people who probably loved
some dickles you this guy probably eats
a [__] ton oh look at this [__] ton of
Chick-fil-A loves the diggle Jews yeah I
mean what kind of nickel juice I don't
know who's standing at the podium this
is the moment
this is the moment stop Whispering
you're gonna scare away the audience and
tickled you so Chris Christie here this
is the moment where he's getting covered
it almost killed him yeah um because
this is him prepping who knows maybe if
he had some tickle juice he would have
been fun that's true this is true just
saying do you think um dickle juice has
the M mRNA in it you think oh yeah it's
also got the 5G well technically it's
got the 5G with the ability to be
upgraded to 6G ooh so it's it's in there
once you take it dude son of a [__] and
loaded which is funny which okay I just
want to point this out
Republicans and mag are like oh my God
the coveted vaccines got 5G we're gonna
be hooked up we're magnetic same people
might I add you okay that look at elon's
neural link and they're like put that
[__] in my brain those are the same
people they get really upset that the
covet vaccine has 5G and microchips and
Bill Gates he's trying to track you and
and they're trying to turn you into
robots so that you follow everything
that they do but then at the same time
they're willing to say you know what
yeah drill a hole into my head and put
the neuralink sensor so that I can be
tracked and possibly die based on all of
the animal test subjects that neuralink
did so you know but what do you say why
I'm all excited listen don't [__]
discourage all the blue checks on
Twitter not to get the [__] Elon
implant when you have a group of people
that there's a there's a disconnect that
this cognitive dissonance this [__]
uh Dunning Krueger like it makes sense
that these would be the people that
would want to put in their head right
oh my God it's just crazy it is amazing
insane it is insane and I want to show
you um the reason why Chris Christie
will never be president of the United
States you want to see it it's one image
and you probably remember when it
happened here it is Chris Christie on
the beach remember when you closed down
the beaches oh yeah cruise is also on
that beach at one point oh really and he
went with his family and only his family
on the beach this is the reason why he
will never and Chris curious to trusts
me when I say you think that's the only
reason I'm pretty sure why I mean
well I get that but it's complicated the
American people don't want to be don't
want to be you know anchored down by
complicated situations that a lot of
people went to prison for what they want
is to give you a reason why you
shouldn't vote for someone and let me
tell you something shutting down beaches
so Chris Christie can go sit in it
[__] and beat shares with his family
so they get to enjoy the beach by
themselves when no one else can that's
enough for a lot of people to say nap
[__] that [__] that guy and that's
what's gonna happen
that's what's gonna happen I I bet I bet
Donald Trump right now is getting an ad
ready that talks about Chris Christie
shutting down the beaches shutting down
the government
because and this is what Rhonda santis
and Donald Trump's gonna [__] get him
on shut down and then keeping the beach
all to himself it's gonna happen man
that's the picture that's going to
destroy
um uh Paul
did one good all right
20 24 Christie for president on the
beach
which is funny because if you look at uh
let me and I wonder if that's a like
obviously that's a dig for that but uh
hold on let me let me just find it
really quick Donald Trump posted a photo
I think from Dan scavino really uh and
it's yeah hold on
it's Dan it is dance giving your arm
it's it's of oh Christmas no no no it's
uh
hold on hold on hold on wait wait
it's it's a photo from the beach and it
spells Trump in a bunch of like these
chairs or uh hold on wait wait yeah just
keep talking I'll find it so so while
you're finding that did you hear this
Jason Vander Beek is trending do you
know Jason yeah yeah yeah yeah man
Dawson's Creek dude yeah Dawson's Creek
and um what's the what's the one movie
he was in the famous One Varsity Blues
Varsity Blues yeah yeah poor guy he's
kind of irrelevant
um he has been since they canceled I saw
he was trending but I don't know why and
he decided it was a good idea to make a
video to show how [__] much he's
changed and aged
um and a lot of people
loved it some people didn't like it and
I think it was like a live and of course
the right Wing's capturing this stuff
um and it really because you you know
the meme uh let's see if I can the
crying one damn here's here's the meme
here's the meme
the famous I mean
um of him crying
um but that's kind of what this was I
think let me see if I can pull this
video his face looked pretty close to
that right but a lot more wrinkly
because he's older obviously look at
look at this gay this guy did not do
that that looks like somebody put a
filter what the [__] man like you know
what people like what the hell happened
like you know when you know when there
was the for a while uh maybe like a year
and a half or two years ago
uh don't make fun of my Dawson I'm not
making sure listen strap in because I'm
gonna make I'm gonna mock the [__] out
of this [__]
but yeah but it honestly just this uh
this like little like uh Freeze Frame
here looks like when people got really
big into taking photos of themselves and
then aging themselves right oh what
would I look like it's so funny
this is real
that dude's he's rough Okay let's listen
to some of the [__] he says that they're
talking about this morning are you
kidding me
there's no debate
over an 80 year old man
if he lives will be the oldest sitting
president in the history of the country
and if he doesn't live as a vice
president whose approval rating is worse
than his
this guy I gotta ask is he talking
backwards or is he walking backwards
because he's trying to figure that like
the steps look off to me like the body
movement I'm like it's not a stride I
don't know maybe maybe he's walking in
place I don't know he can't he can't
walk in like I'm gonna talk about Joe
Biden is there a dog is that a leash is
there a dog somewhere and he's waiting
for the dog is that a jump rope like I I
don't know man I don't know I'm still
stuck on I'm still stuck on what the
hell is going on here uh where where's
CB did CB leave I don't know we're gonna
keep we're gonna keep going here
strap in all right let's let's see what
else what else he has the this in place
Walker who's got the age filter no
filter on have to say who is he still
relevant that's all I want to know I
have no idea obviously declining mental
faculties you're putting him up in front
of a Podium with flashcards telling him
who to call on and what the questions
are going to be
and you're telling us there's no debate
what about the will of the people
okay so okay this is it's almost you
know
honestly under the belief now that he's
standing in front of a like a you know
when you know how people have those
setups they're like I'm running in the
forest and I have like a whole scene
around me right it's like I'm running
down this path
something isn't right I gotta look up
this video because something isn't right
to me when I'm watching it through this
through the preview right here
and I got to figure out what is is
different when I watched it I watched it
with the sound off first because I'm
like what the [__] because it said he
was trending for uh for he's bitching
about Biden not debating Marianne
Williamson and I'm like what what why is
he bitching about him her him not why is
someone so irrelevant as Jason Vander
Beek right bitching about
someone so irrelevant is Marianne
Williamson debating the sitting
president of the United States the
incumbent why why are we doing this and
I watch it with the sound off and it was
confusing to me I'm like is he walking
in place is he walking backwards what is
he doing I didn't even have the sound on
because I I honestly oh you know okay I
watched the okay okay okay yes yes it is
he is walking you have to watch the full
video on Tick Tock he is walking back
it's just a tick tock live or something
no no no it's just a tick tock video
that he posted on Memorial day but the
reason it looks so weird is because all
right so he's out walking he and he
starts but he's like ah it's Memorial
Day I'm out walking with my kids right
and and he's this dog's in the
background
he's got what looks like probably
strapped to his waist
and he's walking backwards and the kids
are in like the little cart
so he's got the cart strapped to him
yeah so he's walking backwards so like
his kids can't walk
I don't know how old his kids are yeah
well I'm just I don't know he's [__]
old look at this guy oh one kid one kid
in it oh one but that's where it starts
where it's like I can't get over the
fact that there's no debate blah blah
that's why it looks so weird is because
he's literally walking backwards with
with a strap that's connected to a
little like Radio Flyer plastic cart and
doing it that's why I see well I've seen
a video here um several weeks or months
ago of him with the kid on his shoulders
and they were picking [__] in the garden
like tomatoes and [__] but this guy look
at his shirt I think I think he ran out
of Dawson's Creek money if you want to
know the honest truth I think he's all
out of that money yeah boy oh oh you
want to know how I feel about Jason
vanderbick
um bitching and moaning and complaining
that Marianne Williamson doesn't get to
debate Joe Biden at not and you're a
dumb Buck if you're worried about
Marianne Williamson debating Joe Biden
because it's not going to happen it's
just not it won't
should get over it you might as well
just live with that truth just like the
truth that Donald Trump is gonna [__]
smash DeSantis and Christy okay yeah
what's this what's this uh here it says
not found what's that found the dance
Gavino thing oh hold on hold on hold on
I mean oh damn it
it says not found this resource cannot
be found
no that's weird it loads for me
I'm telling you what maybe they just
deleted it and you still got it in here
I sold ISO load it up right now okay let
me share my screen really quick let me
no reset in the link oh you just want to
prove that you can [__] [__] because
I'm [__] you think Dan scavino has me
blocked because I am a true social but
I'm not logged into it right online
I've got the app
all right add it
well this is what is in
uh that's that's what you were trying to
send me this is what I was trying to
send you this is dance Gavino on true
social and so when you sh when you
showed that uh
Chris Christie the Chris Christie meme
from uh from Paul this is what it
reminded me of
hmm
and and Trump retweeted this he
recruited Tony whatever
when is he getting back on Twitter man I
want him back on Twitter everyone else
is like oh no I don't know but I'm like
according to to Benny Johnson or as I
like to call him Benji because it's a
[__] dog's name
he says he says guaranteed he says
guaranteed uh that Trump will come back
to Twitter and if that's [__] true
then fine I don't [__] care I mean
it's only gonna make this [__] way more
entertaining because they're going to be
attacking each other literally on the
same platform now so no longer do we
have to say oh did you see what Trump
said over here about this person now
he's gonna be [__] bitching and
whining about other people that he
supposedly was friends with and
supported but now is uh
is is going to be doing the same place
so we can all watch it kind of [__]
blow up together it's gonna be great
right and Elon Musk who you know really
really struggling with the with the
valuation has already lost oh we're
gonna get to that yeah we're gonna get
to that but I want to go first to
another guy who likes really
young women apparently did you hear that
Al Pacino is having 82 years old man
he's
83.83 or 382. I don't know either way I
saw it this morning I was like damn that
guy is old and that is a young young uh
girlfriend not even his wife well so his
Al Pacino is 83 he's expecting I think
this is his fourth child with his 29
year old girlfriend
yeah she's smoking hot by the way that
is crazy like just thinking of the age I
would be like
but the idea that you're like that's the
trick for 83 is you just go at the very
end probably yeah yeah that's what you
do you really go out
but but it's crazy to be like 83
the kid won't even be an adult
and Al Pacino will be lucky if he gets
to 100.
that's crazy stuff right like this is
crazy you're like oh this kid isn't 18
like no [__] way he lasts to be 100
or 101. right when this news popped up
last night I said it out loud at the
table and my wife's like men suck so bad
they suck where's total trash we're
total trash
I need to populate the world even more
like you get your chance sit down all
right right it's like now sit down you
had other Christ wife or wives I don't
know but you're with a girlfriend [__]
man I don't know there's something weird
do you have someone who is you know 29
83 what is that 50 40. I mean again I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna age no I know
but also it's like I don't know man it's
that okay whatever maybe she wanted it
maybe if she wanted a kid and you keep
coming down the line right and you're
like oh you weren't even born yet he was
54 years old right it's there's a
there's a point where like it's a little
it's a little weird I'm look you can do
what you want but it's like this is a
little weird how old was he when she was
born
54.
you're the [__] Grandpa when she was
born 54.
I mean
some people are saying it's [__]
gross I mean again to each its own I I
don't know it's not it doesn't seem like
it would be fun
for her well for him he's like oh yeah
okay I got a young girl but for him it's
like [__]
I mean he's [__] Super Rich right I
mean it's Al Pacino he's probably got a
lot of [__] money
and uh money that can afford any
lifestyle that anyone would want and I'm
not saying I'm in love with Al Pacino
but I could see how hanging out with him
would be kind of cool it's Al Pacino
right hey I'm Al Pacino huh
it wouldn't be fun to hang out with this
guy though oh my God this guy oh [__]
did you hear Twitter Twitter's only
worth 33 yeah and people are like who
the [__] is
actually has a part ownership of [__]
Twitter you [__] idiot so wait a
second wait a second so you're saying
people in the part ownership that are
invested in this thing going God damn we
lost 66 of our investment yeah already
there's a Twitter there's a Twitter
growth fund that Fidelity offers
and wait what did you say
it again a Twitter growth fund how is
there yeah
it doesn't seem like it's growing yeah I
I mean I'm just saying but if you if in
in that access article they break it
down they're like oh in January it was
like eight point something billion right
in terms of what their stake was right
at this growth fund and then their
Fidelity infidelity right right and then
and then they were like uh in in
February or March or whatever it was
like seven point something right and
then now it's like six point something
and remember this is a 30-day period but
they're behind so that was that was
April so we don't know what may is going
to be it's probably going to be even
less than that
but when people are like oh man who the
[__] is Fidelity it's like not they got
a stake in this thing okay they're
involved they're not just any Rando
[__] assessing someone's value
they're the ones who actually have
the inside track as to what the
valuation of a company they're invested
in or they have a part investment in
right
uh what the hell is going on okay Jim
Justice you remember Jim Justice
used to be a Democrat name is Trump and
he turned and he's the he's the governor
of West Virginia okay
um
it's apparently doj is suing the West
Virginia Republican Governor former is
he the governor now I think he's the
governor now Jim just is to collect five
million dollars in fines
um Jim Justice he's he's a he's got a
coal Empire is what they're calling he's
a he's a he owns the coal mines and he's
got five million dollars in unpaid fines
and apparently the Department of Justice
has filed a civil complaint against him
and uh 13 coal companies that he owns is
Jim Justice owned 13 coal companies it's
you know what it's kind of like it's
kind of like if you own like 20 buggy
whip companies in it wouldn't that be a
[__] if you're like I have a
buggy wimpin buggy whip Empire like yeah
okay what is this [__] what is this
the night 1890s what the [__]
you're on 13 cold companies they're
still cold you're still digging for that
[__] it's kind of weird I'm just saying
it's kind of weird in 2023 that you
would have an Empire of coal companies
again it's kind of like having an Empire
of buggy whip companies do you think is
he is he how big is his Empire of coal
employees I'm sure it's almost nothing
because he can't really it's it costs so
much [__] money to to actually mine
for coal that you can't hardly sell it
because no one buys it yeah I mean it
wasn't wasn't at one point weren't there
less coal miners than there were Arby's
restaurants is that what it was is that
what the comparison oh no it's about
time we boycott Arby's though having
said that why not I'm sure I'm sure
they're but have you seen the shape of
that it looks like a dick it does it
does and I'm just saying
gender of the hat is where's the beef
sounds real erotic to me Tony we have
the meats they got the meats baby I do
hey Joey hey Joey you better look into
um the sauce over there though the
Horsey Sauce over there at uh now Arby's
you might might find some good stuff in
there Joey oh yeah oh [__] what else we
got we got um Hakeem Jeffries is
trending there's something oh lizard
always slaying slaying on the house
floor I don't know I would imagine when
he's trending it's either two locations
he either drops some [__] at the podium
inside of the press room or he drops
some [__] in the actual like Chambers
in the in the chambers drops them he
drops them he drops he drops a big bomb
are you frozen
is Tony Frozen
oh God damn it what's going on Tony Tony
can people hear me right now now that
Tony's off the air since he seems to be
having technical difficulties
uh it's now the game show you're gonna
get a little bit of a presentation of
what the game show is going to be while
Tony is off doing whatever he's doing
next week oh low quality bitrate Tony
back in the game I tell you what I was
actually terrified this morning because
when I when I um
when I got up this morning
my power was off they're doing like tree
trimming around to me dude they're
trimming bushes and trees and [__] yeah
I know they're trimming [__] around
the power lines and I figured maybe they
[__] up the power line like ah God
damn it but then it came on when I went
downstairs started my coffee it came
right on
okay back on it came right on the back
on okay so they're mad at lizzo is big I
guess and that she like
well that too
um they're are they still mad that she
[__] used that was it James Madison
Crystal flute and she played it in DC
Smithsonian oh
I I don't know
um she was mad they were [__] pissed
about that I think they're they're mad
that she's she's a big girl but she's
still confident did you know confidence
is is pretty sexy did you know that yeah
I think it is
I wish I had the confidence that she has
I'll say that much like she should
confident yeah I know I'm saying like I
wish I had that confidence she's got
that confidence and I I wouldn't say
that I really have all of that
confidence you know here here's the
video that some people are using to try
to Fat shame her uh let's see body
shamer here you go I'm gonna turn it off
because they'll bang me on the copyright
but this is the there's probably still
this is the Tic Tac
hold on hold on hold on they really
think that posting a video of her of her
wearing this choosing to do this
performance at her own show is going to
make her feel bad I don't know do you
know how much money she probably made
doing this oh dude so much money so I
think this is the same show where she
came out and she's saying Tina Turner's
because you know Tina Turner died yes
and she's saying team to turn I think
this is the same show but but again
folks if you're upset that lizzo is a
little heavy and she's still got
confidence and she's still got the skill
to run around stage and dance and sing
like that maybe you're focusing on the
wrong thing I don't know yeah I don't
know maybe you step away from the semen
frosted lemonades and maybe take a real
deep look inside and say
what am I drinking
and for anybody
does this have steam in it wait I'm
sorry this it's like that it's like that
did you [__] Super Troopers hey does
this does this look like spit yeah
so let me ask when you go into
Chick-fil-A because I know they got an
app and they probably got the like the
the the the kiosk where you can order
yourself yeah yeah right so when you go
in and you order the lemonade does it
have an option
to add the semen or does it
automatically it might be so I I would I
would imagine well it's also the Frozen
because that's a again I don't even I
didn't even know
I haven't been to Chick-fil-A in years
because it's like never around so I
don't ever go there it's what the idea
is
expensive sandwich it's a really
expensive chicken you can go anywhere
else and get chicken
that's just as good that doesn't taste
like dickle juice and and eat chicken
somewhere I mean I've seen multiple
videos on Instagram reels where
somebody's like I'm gonna show you how
to make your own homemade
Chick-fil-A sandwich and I was like damn
that looks pretty [__] good right I
was like the crunch the grease they are
good they are good but the thing is is
they're not that good yeah I'm saying
I'm saying these homemade ones look
pretty good oh I see I see so you're
saying they may be better than that I'm
saying original if you can spend the
quality time to focus on that one
chicken you know a one-to-one connection
made in the kitchen
I would have to assume that it there's
multiple things that taste good about it
right the chicken itself everything
together and the fact that you made it
right it's your creation you made it
with your hands
and then you'll be even more excited
when you have that semen Frost and
lemonade
homemade right
here's uh King Jeffries I don't this guy
doesn't look like he drinks frosted
lemonade with
semen in it I don't I mean I don't know
maybe I'm sure he also doesn't get
pissed off about random dumb arbitrary
fake outrage type of oh I mean he stays
on message yeah yeah that's kind of
funny okay uh let's go to King Jeffries
I like his [__] tie you know that the
color of that tie that's confidence baby
I like it I like it you know what he he
[__] cleans up nice this guy knows
how to wear a suit yeah that's one thing
I like about a king he knows how to wear
a suit
like the senator from Pennsylvania knows
how to wear a hoodie you know what I
mean like they both look good both look
good but he knows how to wear a suit
let's see what he's saying about the
debt limit and the debt ceiling and
let's see if we can um
talk a little bit about debt ceiling
that's going to pass with flying colors
because Democrats and Kevin McCarthy may
not be speaker anymore because of it
which is kind of kind of shoots is that
the shortest tenure of a speaker I don't
know but probably we're talking
we're I mean what he's only been speaker
for like three months he's barely been
speaker for that amount of time too I
mean he barely got it if he makes it six
months that they voted on it took him to
get him to be speakers about as long as
he is speaker but here's the thing
here's the thing is that this this debt
ceiling if you don't like it well you're
not paying attention but here's the
thing is that here's what you might like
about it a Democrats are going to vote
for this [__] and it is possible
that Republicans get pissed off enough
that they just get rid of Kevin McCarthy
so not only does the debt ceiling raise
we pushed we kicked the [__] the
budget can pass the election so they
can't do that [__] no more so they got
anything to argue over they don't got
any anything to hold all against us you
needing to hold hostage against us and
here's the thing and Kevin McCarthy is
then not speaker and they don't have a
speaker and they can't figure out who
the speaker is you think that's bad
that's great politics watch a king
Jeffries he thinks it's great too let's
listen
some things that were incredibly
important to the American people
all of which were on the chopping block
because of the extreme Mega Republicans
God this guy said they're Ransom demands
damn he's good at this from the very
beginning of this year
but because President Biden held the
line
some very important things were
protected
in this resolution
President Biden protected Social
Security
President Biden protected Medicare
President Biden protected Medicaid
President Biden protected veterans
President Biden protected
the inflation reduction Act
President Biden protected the clean
energy tax credits that will be
transformational
President Biden protected billions of
dollars in funding
so combat
environmental Injustice
and President Biden protected the
American people
from the types of devastating Cuts
proposed by right wing
extremists
that would have hurt Millions
of everyday Americans
that was all accomplished
as a result of this resolution
and I'm thankful for the leadership of
President Biden house Democrats who
stood strongly behind him
and his administration leader Schumer
and Senate Democrats as well
excuse me he goes on to say in this
speech that Democrats are going to vote
for this thing the caucus is behind of
course there's a few Democrats out there
like
oh we didn't we we we gotta find
something to [__] about yeah we know
you gotta yeah I would love I would I
would have loved for him to be like and
I definitely want to thank Kevin
McCarthy for coming to the table and
agreeing to this resolution because then
you're like oh great not only are we
gonna actually vote on this thing but
you just threw this [__] under
the bus to now be eaten by the other
leopards right like it's it's too good
it's too beautiful of a moment it would
have if if I were him I would have been
like oh when I and I want to give a
special shout out to Kevin McCarthy for
coming with a serious set of talking
points right and wanting to help the
American people uh Michael on YouTube
makes a good point tyt will be against
this of course they will of course of
course they will because they're
self-defeatist they don't understand a
win when they get it politically right
and they don't understand not only do
they not know a political win when the
left gets it but they don't know how to
run laps around Republicans when you get
that win and it's the same same way with
the midterms right right like it was
supposed to say a [__] shutout
oh
30 40 seats whatever and then they only
got like a handful of seats right
it feels like it feels like we're
finally convincing folks here because
welcome to the party and I don't know if
you guys have always felt that way about
tyt but um [__] on them is so easy
and the reason why is because there's
such [__] they're just [__] and and
people attack me
um when I go after them oh you're going
after the left you shouldn't go after
them they go after the left I'm like are
you listening to what you're saying
you're saying don't attack them because
they go after the left but I'm attacking
the left when I go after them are you
not anyways okay here's a king Jeffries
um giving his support in the speech I
believe this is the clip where he's
saying they're gonna vote for it was a
very thoughtful comprehensive
uh Clear Eye discussion
about the moment that we are in
and of course about the importance
of avoiding a catastrophic default
in that meeting I made clear
that I'm going to support
the legislation that is on the floor
today
and then I support it
without hesitation reservation or
trepidation
not because it's perfect
but in divided government we of course
cannot allow the perfect to be the enemy
of the good there you go there's the
king Jeffries giving his message you
wonder why this guy is the leader in the
minority right now I'm probably going to
be one of the most powerful one of the
most uh one of longest serving speakers
of the house that right there and right
there that guy that guy knows exactly
what he's doing
um he knows the politics he knows the
game he knows the messaging he knows he
has to do it and honestly as as
effective as a of a speaker of the house
that Nancy Pelosi was Hakeem Jeffries I
believe will probably run away with that
effect in this long past long past Nancy
Pelosi and the reason why is because
he's learned from her learn from the
best but he's way better at messaging
he's way better at at whipping not just
his caucus but using media to whip
support in the party so I I think I
think a king Jeffries is a big star in
the Democratic party in the
pro-democracy Coalition and I believe
it's up to us to make sure that that guy
is the leader in the house and he's the
speaker of the house it's up to us to
make him the longest serving speaker of
the house and we must hold that line
um he's so good at his job he's very
very [__] good at it because the
speaker's job is not just and the
leader's job is not just about making
sure the rules and you get what your
caucus needs the tools that they have to
have to get the work done but also that
you're giving the messaging and that the
country is hearing you when you're
speaking and Hakeem Jeffrey says damn
good at that so I'm glad that he's
training I'm glad that those
um those are um those are moving around
the internet yeah oh let's see what else
do we got here we got a few minutes left
is there anything else that we miss that
you wanted to talk about today I know
tomorrow's Thursday so we got um bone
Hen of the week vote tomorrow
I don't know what else happened so go
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod follow us there for the bone of the
week poll also follow is here on YouTube
don't forget to subscribe go to the
community tab this evening you'll be
able to see the bone end of the week
poll you've been a vote there also if
you want to watch the Tony Michaels
podcast live on Facebook go to Tony
Michaels follow us there follow us on
the books of faith and I want to say
thank you to all the people over there
on Twitch that that twitch chat is
growing and growing and growing did you
notice that like there's a ton of people
so what some people send me a message
said hey I want you on the on my TV like
on YouTube on the app and then I get in
the twitch chat so they're like they're
chatting with twitch and they're on the
TV with with YouTube so that's kind of
cool
um so everyone go to twitch.tv slash the
Tony Michaels you can actually tie your
Prime account to your Twitch account and
give us that one free subscription with
your Prime account it gives us a couple
bucks each month look into doing that
just go to the Tony michaels.com that's
the Tony michaels.com while you're there
check out my patreon why not check out
my patreon while you're there why not
why not just click the button and while
you're on patreon check out games I know
he's gonna have what was that's coming
or you can go to yeah what was that
show.com that's what was that sure.com
it'll take you directly to his patreon
and check out all the extras and all the
Early Access that you get to those
episodes one episode coming out later
today I got another one maybe coming out
tomorrow
okay so before we go you know what I'm
talking about when you're talking about
next Monday and Tuesday oh no the
audience told the audience that you are
going to be you are going to be the host
of the Gabe Sanchez podcast
on Monday yeah um and I'm gonna make it
I'm gonna I'm just gonna make a new logo
and it's all right Gabe Sanchez [__] you
I'm gone for one goddamn date so two
days you're going for two that is two
days and while it's possible I took I I
made sure two days just in case all
right because there is possible what are
you doing where are you going I mean
there may be a little bit of alcohol
involved soon oh okay all right
I take over Monday I got Texas Paul on
Tuesday right so I was what I was
thinking is you should get some you
should get a guest on Monday or a guest
host yeah because Texas ball will help
you host on Tuesday he's always yeah
yeah I want to know I should get maybe
okay here people and I can't say that I
can make it happen right but tomorrow uh
because obviously we only have like you
know we have the show's over now but
tomorrow and Friday maybe you guys
suggest someone that I should try to get
on the show as a co-host there you go
and they can co-host with you yeah now
I'm gonna have to give you the rundown
because do you know the tick tock of the
beginning of the show how all this stuff
man I just throw [__] up whatever you
got the first 30 minutes it's about the
topic of them with the show no no I'm
talking I'm talking about when you enter
into the stream because you got to pull
the loop up right yeah yeah and then
Resolute the elevator music and then and
then what you do what you do is you
click the intro music okay and then you
gotta you gotta go down and you gotta
put yourself in the broadcast because
you can't be in the broadcast you got to
be out of the broadcast yeah from the
elevator music to the right music right
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're telling the
audience how this works and you can see
that Tick Tock that happens so then then
what you have to do is you have to
include you and your screen but then you
have to move it to you being full
picture which sometimes I do not get
totally on the point right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then when when the
music starts to die that's when you can
unmute and then you can oh so that's how
it works so maybe so maybe we'll go
through the tick tock if you need to
yeah maybe we'll do it we'll do it you
know check out some practice runs yeah
this afternoon tomorrow you know that's
how it works ah
anybody anybody who wants uh Gabe uh as
a guest co-host suggestion make sure to
go I got people people I could do it
people saying get Ben people saying get
popoc I see some gadera uh uh who else
who else I don't know you could you
could some people saying Texas Paul on
Monday and Tuesday Monday and I don't
know that's that get President Biden
okay yeah let me just call in a favor
that would be one hell of a show you
know I've got here's the best one yet uh
George Santos and barn well I think
those would be good too someone over
here says George Santos and if I didn't
already burn that bridge
I would totally invite him on the show
here's the thing he doesn't you know
here I'll do this I'll do this for the
show
um you can get Ed or Brian they're
saying Francis team oh I could yeah yeah
okay here all right Rachel Rachel you
can do doctor just to give people an
idea this is
uh I think this is because of me
you mean you mean something that George
Santos did yeah yeah they're saying Jess
Piper Dr Rachel these are all good
suggestions hey Trump get Trump on the
show he would be a good guest to us yeah
sure your call has been forwarded to an
automated voice messaging system yeah
that would be uh George Santos he
doesn't answer his cell phone anymore he
might have changed his number
it goes straight to voicemail which
means it's like the the line is still
active but I think he's turned it off
permanently and he's moved over to a new
number
um
poor guy well let's see if we can think
of a um a co-host yeah or a get or even
just a guest for you on on Monday yeah
somebody wants to know did I ever reach
Trump's lawyer no it's been uh I can't
reach him the voicemail is is uh is full
of messages
we'll totally let you know when we get
to leave a voice yeah we get an answer
to our question did Trump write that
letter or did the attorney uh write that
letter oh Rudy Giuliani that that you
know what Rudy Giuliani actually
unblocked me so maybe I should message
did he really he unblocked me on Twitter
which is really weird so strange as [__]
isn't it now I'm kind of curious why if
I should reach out to him and say hey
would you be willing to come on the show
uh we'd love to interview you do you
think they were using unblocking tools
or do you think they're like ah that
gave Sanchez give him a chance I don't
know that's a good question but I just
know right now that I am no longer
blocked by Rue Giuliani I was at one
point it might have been because I was
sending him DMs but whatever uh
what what were you putting in his DMs I
was just you know I was just sending him
the the my proposed Chick-fil-A menu
oh I see yeah yeah what you would put in
the yeah in the lemonade is that with
you yeah yeah okay who knows maybe now
okay hell that'd be good you know maybe
but now but does Hal do a show on Monday
I don't know I think I know he does
maybe say Thursday right we always have
sparklers in here and so yeah yeah um
who knows maybe maybe during the show
I'll do something special I'll put the
green screen up I'll put the [__] wig
on who knows I can be any number of
characters maybe the show it's just a
new character a new maybe that's what
I'll do is I'll have a new character
every like all four characters maybe and
every like 30 months take a break and a
very new character you know you know the
other thing yeah the other thing I need
to do I need to get that boycott binder
ad yeah I keep saying that I need to get
it in the rotation yeah I need to get in
the rotation yeah I'm slow to do things
I'm kind of a bonehead but you know what
you know what we got now you know what
we got right now right now it's
store.the Tony michaels.com we gotta let
them eat rake because they need to keep
eating Rank and they're going to keep
stepping on rake so you're gonna want
this shirt let them eat rake at store
not the Tony michaels.com we'll get a
sticker and possibly hoodie up this
afternoon I'll do that too so we get the
boycott binder and some of the let them
eat rake so go to
store.thetonymichaels.com get your let
them eat rake merch now before it's all
gone nuts I'm just kidding it's none of
that it's like print on demand so as
many as you want to buy and then we've
had several dozen sold already yes thank
you very much for the support thank you
for coming today and listening to us on
hump day May 31st tomorrow marks marks
maga maga mind exploding pride month
same time same place
Surfside [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon